mallorca magazin meldet für den tag
verleiht mit einer euro reformation und
bestimmt neuen leiter für glück
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit dem überflug der drei eurofighter
startete unsere dynamische vorführung
die ihnen heute einen einblick in das
berufsfeld eines leutnants und die
mögliche einsatz aufgaben eines jungen
leuten und geben sollen
im bereich der luftraumüberwachung zu
der die drei eurofighter gehören gibt es
übrigens nicht nur piloten sondern auch
unsere überflieger am boden dazu zählen
technische offiziere flug sicherer und
reiter offiziere mehr dazu zur
luftraumüberwachung und zu den
luftstreitkräften generell gibt es dann
bei der airpower 22 wir freuen uns wenn
wir sie dort wiedersehen
wir das sind hauptmann anna kaiser
assistenzprofessorin für
kulturgüterschutz in meiner miliz
funktion kommandantin der jäger kompanie
toolan und 2016 hier ausgemustert und
hauptmann marcel schweer pressesprecher
des bundesheeres und 2013 hier
ausgemustert wir freuen uns sie heute
durch die dynamische vorführung zu
begleiten
ja auch heute sorgen unsere
militärpolizisten wieder für ordnung und
sicherheit
hier haben unsere kameraden demonstriert
wie sie eine offensichtlich störende
person durch muskelkraft und technik zu
boden bringen und somit den
reibungslosen ablauf der weiteren show
gewährleisten
unter realen umständen würde der störer
jetzt an die polizei übergeben werden
und dort weiter behandelt wie wir
militärpolizisten zu sagen pflegen aber
die militärpolizei macht das sicherlich
weit mehr als nur angst zu behandeln
völlig richtige werner angeführt von
einem motorrad welches auch im
stadtverkehr höchste mobilität bietet
steigen aus dem bus mehrere soldaten aus
und pries repräsentieren die
unterschiedlichen aufgaben der
militärpolizei wir sehen einen
personenschützer der im in und ausland
wie zum beispiel in mali zum einsatz
kommt einen hundeführer der mit seinem
hund sowohl sprengstoff als auch trugen
sucht und findet einen soldaten der
speziell geschützt ist um bei
demonstrationen zum einsatz kommt um für
ruhe und ordnung zu sorgen einem
präzisionsschützen der das eigene
vorgehen der militärpolizisten sichert
und dabei auf größere distanzen präzise
wirkungstreffer erzielen kann sowie
einen sogenannten zugreife zugreife sind
dafür ausgebildet hausdurchsuchungen zu
machen und straftäter zu überwältigen
und dieses gesamte spektrum wird von den
jungen leute nannten abgedeckt
heute aber danken wir der militärpolizei
ganz besonders dafür dass sie diese und
weitere veranstaltungen sicher macht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
um einsätze auch richtig planen und
durchführen zu können müssen einige
informationen bereits im vorfeld bekannt
sein im militär nennen wir das aufklären
und dafür haben wir auch heute echte
spezialisten hier anna ist die bereits
was aufgefallen
aber natürlich auf der linken seite von
den zuseherinnen ausgesehen haben wir
das so genannte boden überwachungsraum
auch beagle genannt es wiegt nur 30 kilo
und kann von zwei soldaten ganz einfach
in rucksäcken transportiert werden mit
dem beagle können die aufklärer
bewegliche ziele erfassen verfolgen
automatisch klassifizieren und auch die
einen koordinaten bestimmen das system
ist in circa fünf minuten aufgebaut und
betriebsbereit und
auf der rechten seite sehe ich einen hus
dabei handelt es sich um ein leicht
gepanzerte des gefechts fahrzeug das im
bundesheer als transport patrol in
führungs- und aufklärungs fahrzeug
eingesetzt wird
der user bietet schutz gegen beschuss
gegen minen sprengfallen und
granatsplitter und sorgt für hohe
mobilität der soldaten auf dem
gefechtsfeld
wir sehen ihn wie er auf den maria
theresienplatz vorfährt
und dann ist mir noch eine dritte sache
aufgefallen marcel hast du dir auch
gesehen
du meinst bestimmt die beiden soldaten
des aufklärungs die wirklich gut getan
sind und so gut einer stunde als unsere
augen und ohren das gesamte geschehen
beobachten
ich lade deine frage aber gerne an die
zuseherinnen und zuseher weiter haben
sie unsere beiden kameraden auch gesehen
beziehungsweise haben sie bemerkt dass
sie beobachtet werden
ich darf die zwei kameraden bieten
ebenfalls auf dem maria theresienplatz
herauszutreten
übrigens finden sie dieses und andere
fotos natürlich in unserem flickr
account des bundesheers
die beiden aufklärer haben einen
beobachtungs und aufklärungs satz mit
einer kamera mit die bis zu 500 fach
vergrößern kann
und die aufgabe der leutnant bei der
aufklärungs truppe wird es sein die
technische und fuß aufklärung zu
koordinieren zu leiten und die
aufklärungsergebnisse an die obere
führung zu übermitteln aber hören wir
uns doch mal an was die aufklärer hier
heute so erkannt haben und an die obere
führung weiter melden
[Musik]
während also die aufklärer vor
gestaffelt sämtliche informationen
ermittelt und aufbereitet haben haben
sich soldaten anderer waffengattungen
auf ihren einsatz vorbereitet dieses
zusammenspiel nennt man kampf der
verbundenen waffen
in gruppenstärke überrascht wäre im
februar
lage
auftragsdurchführung wir treten wetter
und steinmeier unterstützung artillerie
wirkungsraum im februar danach wechselte
kampf sehr kreativ die vertrieblichen
öffentlicher schwere trennung nach
deprimiert zum räumen auf dem alle
kommen
auf der linken vorderen seite hat sich
nun die m109
panzerhaubitzen stellung gebracht dieses
waffensystem gehört zur artillerie- und
wäre normalerweise bis zu 28 kilometer
in der tiefe des gefechts als teil der
feier unterstützung eingesetzt hören wir
uns doch das feuer kommando gemeinsam an
das geschehen oder achtung feuer
kommandos sprengladung 85 hektar ladung
im teatro aufschlagzünder setzte die
unterstrich erhöhung 650 rhythmus
maximal feuern sofort
[Musik]
jetzt haben das gefühl nur gehofft sagt
unverändert fort abschnitt stelle im
playboy der markenwert von 70 punkten
auf
der stelle bewegt
wir nennen
mit der unterstützung der artillerie
greifen die panzergrenadiere an sie sind
gemeinsam mit den kampfpanzern der
starke mechanisierte rückgrat des
bundesheeres sie sind in der lage
aufgrund ihrer ausrüstung mit dem
schützenpanzer ulan und ihrer
hervorragenden ausbildung rasch und
flexibel auf jede lage entwicklung zu
reagieren
[Musik]
mit zutritt
ihr 18
wenn die eigene beweglichkeit am
gefechtsfeld behindert wird wie hier
maria theresienplatz durch einen
sogenannten spanischen reiter dann ist
es an der zeit für unsere pioniere
[Musik]
die pioniere haben die aufgabe und das
equipment sperren und hindernisse zu
errichten aber auch sie zu beseitigen
und damit bewegungsmöglichkeiten für die
eigenen soldaten zu schaffen
[Musik]
die leute nach der pionier truppe müssen
aber viel mehr können sie koordinieren
die hilfeleistung bei katastrophen
fällen und bei verheerenden
naturereignissen und sind damit eine
hilfe für die bevölkerung überall dort
wo zivile hilfsmaßnahmen nicht mehr
reichen sei es bei hochwasser schnee
sturm katastrophen oder moon und
felsstürzen
oftmals ist der einsatz unter
lebensgefahr notwendig
[Musik]
kommt
heute zwar nicht vor ort aber im gefecht
nicht wegzudenken unser kampfpanzer
leopard 2 a 4 eines der weltweit
modernsten kampffahrzeuge
[Musik]
ausbruch vorbereitet
herbert wollen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber nicht alle gefahren sind immer
gleich sichtbar und so augenscheinlich
wieder spanische reiter der soeben
geräumt wurde
in vielen ländern lager nach wie vor
atomare biologische und chemische
kampfstoffe im militär sprechen wir
dabei von abc kampfstoffen aber auch
dafür haben wir doch sicherlich
spezialisten im bundesheer oder
natürlich heute sehen wir die
spezialisten der abc abwehr mit zwei
ihrer fahrzeuge im einsatz hier sehen
wir den dingo 2 die spieler des abc
aufklärungs zuges die jetzt gerade
vorgehen liefern dem kommandanten
detaillierte informationen zu einer
möglichen kontamination mit
gefahrenstoffen sie können diese stoffe
zweifelsfrei zuordnen und ermöglichen
damit auch das rechtzeitig
schutzmaßnahmen eingeleitet werden
originale objekt aufgeklärt
die verpflichtungen die cam unendliche
keine anzeige vor
sollte es dennoch dazu kommen dass
eigene soldaten kontaminiert werden wir
mit dem zweiten fahrzeug dem mammut das
soeben vorfährt eine dekontamination
durchgeführt eine dekontamination
beinhaltet alle maßnahmen zur entgiftung
einstrahlung entseuchung und wesen
ein dekontamination zug kann pro tag
zirka zwölf stunden
arbeiten
ein dekontamination zug kann
kann pro stunde ca 40 personen
dekontaminieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
als gelernte infanteristen darf ich mit
der vorstellung der jäger truppe
beginnen die jäger truppe stellt den
zahlenmäßig größten anteil der
österreichischen kampftruppen und ist
das bollwerk und rückgrat des
bundesheeres in kritischen situationen
sind die jäger meistens als erster zur
stelle
sie benutzten leichte waffen und sind
deshalb sehr beweglich
heute sehen wir den pandur evolution ein
gepanzertes fahrzeug das den soldaten im
inneren schutz vor splittern vor
beschuss und familien bietet dank der
beschaffungs initiativen der frau
bundesminister verfügt das bundesheer
hier über das neueste gerät
nach dem 73 prozent
des österreichischen staatsgebiet
[Musik]
nach dem 73 des österreichischen
staatsgebiet es als berggebiet gelten
braucht es auch hier spezialfahrzeuge
die während alle jahreszeiten und im
schwierigsten gelände also auch abseits
von straßen einsetzbar sind der
sogenannte hätte uns ist aber nicht nur
in der lage elf personen zu
transportieren sondern bietet auch
schutz vor waffen wirkung radioaktiven
und chemischen kampfstoffen und er hat
sogar eine klimaanlage sowie eine
heizung die
typische erst verwendung eines leutnants
ist die des zugs kommandanten der junge
offizier trägt bei der jäger truppe die
verantwortung für die ausbildung und
führung von rund 40 soldaten das
spektrum verdeutlichen uns die
abgesessenen soldaten vor ort die
unterschiedlichen adjustierungen
repräsentieren die soldaten in ihren
natürlichen habitat im winter daran zug
sind die soldaten auch bestens im schnee
getan ein soldat der bei den
assistenzeinsatz zur unterstützung
ziviler behörden bereit ist sehen wir
ebenfalls vor ort
einen soldaten der im ordnungs einsatz
eingesetzt werden kann und für
zivilschutz bereitsteht zusätzlich ist
dieser soldat mit einer schrotflinte
ausgestattet und weitere soldaten an
seiner seite die für die klassischen
aufgaben der landesverteidigung
verantwortlich sind sie alle stehen
sowohl im inland als auch im ausland
jederzeit für die pflichterfüllung
bereit und verdeutlichen hier die
vielfalt der jäger truppe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
neben den land und luftstreitkräften
verfügt das bundesheer aber auch über
spezialeinsatzkräfte den anti-terror-
verband des österreichischen
bundesheeres das jahr kommando sie
trainieren für einsätze und der
schwierigsten gelände und
witterungsbedingungen sowie bei extremen
gefahrensituationen und sind die erst
reaktions kraft des bundesheeres
jederzeit und weltweit
im heutigen szenario werden wir sehen
wie die soldaten des jagdkommandos unter
vor gestaffelte aufklärung und
informationsgewinnung zwei fahrzeuge
auch geklärt haben die dann in weiterer
folge maria theresien platz einfahren
bei den insassen dieser beiden fahrzeuge
handelt es sich um terroristen mit einem
anführer und einer geisel um die
fahrzeuge zu stoppen wird durch eine
sand lieber die straße gesperrt und die
terroristen blockiert gesichert wird das
ganze geschehen dabei von scharfschützen
die aus dem hubschrauber das geschehen
mitverfolgen und jederzeit aktionen
setzen können um weitere soldaten werden
sich aus dem s 70 black hawk abseilen
und das so genannte fast roten
durchführen
genug meiner worte
genießen wir die show
innerhalb kürzester zeit ist die
befreiung der geiseln und den westen
aber der straftäter abgeschlossen
wesentlich dabei sind der
überraschungseffekt und die präzision
gepaart mit unterschiedlichsten
spezialisten so land in der luft und im
wasser
einfach beeindruckend wie diese
elitesoldaten unkonventionell und
kreativ probleme lösen zuletzt waren es
übrigens in afghanistan und haben
während der krisenhaften entwicklungen
dort ihren einsatz in ein
unterstützungsteam geleistet um
österreichische staatsbürger wieder
sicher nach hause zu holen
und bevor wir nun
und bevor wir nun zum ende der
dynamischen vorführung kommen möchten
wir aber noch weitere waffengattungen
vor dem vorhang holen und unseren
aufrichtigen dank aussprechen die
sanitätsgruppe die sich heute wie so oft
bei veranstaltungen des bundesheeres und
die medizinische notfallversorgung
kümmert die logistiker ohne deren
unterstützung es keine versorgung und
damit auch keine festakte geben würde
und die fördermenge gruppe d nicht nur
kabel verlegt sondern auch die
kommunikation sicherstellt
aber jetzt haben wir genug geredet und
darüber geben das wort an unseren
kommandanten und organisator der
dynamischen vorführung ein oberst
lampersberger der oberst in diesem sinn
meldet sich die moderation ab vielen
dank
frau bundesminister oberst landsberger
command der dynamischen vorführung
gestaltet von 117 soldatinnen und
soldaten der dritten jägerbrigade der
vierte panzergrenadierbrigade der 6 die
brigade der siebten jägerbrigade des
kommandos luftraumüberwachung des
kommandos luftunterstützung des
jagdkommandos sowie der militärpolizei
meldet die beendigung der vorführung ist
erfolgt nun der einmarsch der
information für den festakt zum tag
treten werde
vielen dank für die beeindruckende
vorführung die ehrenformation
einmarschieren lassen die information
einmarschieren lassen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin ein bisschen vor
st
darf ich ihnen und die aufstellung
bekanntgeben ich begegne dazu von mir
aus gesehen links
beginnt sehen sie die gardemusik unter
der leitung von landes kapellmeister
oberstleutnant hans kraus danach die
fahne der militärakademie den fahnen und
standarten blog des österreichischen
bundesheeres sowie das ehepaar de jong
vor mir dass dem ersten und 2 jahrgang
ihnen gegenüber stehen die zu
übernehmenden berufs und medizin es
folgen der jahrgang freiherr lenkt von
wolfsberg mit offiziersanwärtern aus
bosnien herzegowina
frankreich lettland litauen montenegro
polen rumänien und den vereinigten
staaten von amerika daran anschließend
die fahne des schutzpatrons in die
kadetten der bundeshandelsakademie für
führen und sicherheit
in wenigen augenblicken erfolgt dann das
angekündigt nachdem an führungs signal
die meldung des kommandanten des
akademiker patrice oberst gerhard
fleisch wand und die frau
bundesministerin für landesverteidigung
magistra klaudia tanner nach dem
abspielen der bundeshymne und der
europahymne erfolgt das abschreiten der
front durch die frau bundesministerin
den chef des generalstabs general
minister robert rieger den kommandanten
der theresianischen militärakademie in
rain minister karl korn hagel sowie dem
bürgermeister von wiener neustadt herrn
klubobmann und abgeordneten zunächst
zwischen landtag magister klaus
schneeberger im anschluss erfolgt die
flaggenparade
die fan hat der theresianischen
militärakademie
der fahnen und standarten blog des
österreichischen bundesheeres die
gardemusik
das ehepaar die zunehmenden offiziere
der burgherren jahrgang mit der
internationalen kadetten die schule für
führung und sicherheit das bürgerportal
stadt total stadt wiener neustadt
abordnungen traditionsverband truck oder
ein gebet 7 auf mein kommando ich
spreche sie an als das ganze
[Musik]
er
repräsentiert
der meldung an die frau bundesminister
das ganze recht
frau bundesminister oberst fleischmann
meldet die fahnen der theresianischen
militärakademie
fahnen und standarten blog des
österreichischen bundesheeres die
gardemusik das gern gestellt vom
akademiker batterien der folkwang
jahrgang mit dem international kadetten
die schule für sicherheit und führung
das prämierte moni von wird die bürger
der stadt total stadt wiener neustadt
abonnement packung auch wer gewinnt 7
anlässlich der übernahme von 97 berufs
und medizin angetreten
für die meldung mit dem festakt beginnen
ihnen
[Musik]
schnell
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ganze
wäre
beinahe
das
ganze
er wolle
[Musik]
das ganze recht
das ganze parade und
es erfolgt nun die begrüßung durch den
kommandanten der militärakademie nach
einem von der militärmusik gespielten
choral hören sie die worte der
geistlichkeit im anschluss daran folgt
die ansprache des chefs des
generalstabes in reinster robert brieger
und danach spielt die gardemusik den 92
regimentsmarsch allen ehren ist
österreich
offiziere des ausmustern des jahres 2021
welche heute feierlich in die
streitkräfte übernommen werden hoch
geschätzte ehren und festgäste
20 21 ist wie 2020 für theresianischen
militärakademie weiterhin ein jahr der
herausforderungen im umgang mit cookies
dennoch sind wir stolz neben unseren
bildungs und forschungsauftrag auch
unseren beitrag in form
unterschiedlicher ansätze zur bekämpfung
der pandemie geleistet zu haben
für den heutigen tag haben wir alle
anstrengungen unternommen um trotz
dieser pandemie im rahmen eines würdigen
festaktes 87 berufs und militär in das
österreichische bundesheer zu übernehmen
berufs und militär haben eine
herausfordernde und ausgezeichnete
ausbildung erhalten mit
unterschiedlichen wegen aber einem
gemeinsamen ziel dienen sie werden
bewegt sein in ihren künftigen
verwendungen und funktionen die
verschiedensten militärischen
herausforderungen zu bewältigen und die
gestellten aufgaben zu erfüllen was es
bedeutet für das dorf is here oder
offizier im österreichischen bundesheer
zu sehen haben sie soeben in einer
kurzen vorführung geliebt
mit dieser kurzen einführung zum
heutigen festakt dadurch sie sehr
geehrte erden festgäste zum tag der
leute und der 20 21 auf das alle
herzlich zu begrüßen mit freude und
respekt begrüßen wir unsere
bundesminister für landesverteidigung
auch in vertretung des herrn
bundespräsidenten und oberbefehlshaber
frau magistra klaudia tanner ein
herzliches willkommen frau bundesmittel
für die vertreter der gesetzgebenden
körperschaften begrüßen wir den
amtsführenden vorsitzenden der
parlamentarischen bundesheerkommission
abgeordneter zum nationalrat magister
friedrich offen aber den vorsitzenden
der parlamentarischen
bundesheerkommission
abgeordneter zum nationalrat robert
langer die abgeordnete zum nationalrat
dr bitte hervor der winkler herrn
bundesrat martin preineder und eingang
songs bürgermeister abgeordnete zählt
ersten landtag und klubobmann in
vertretern der frau landeshauptfrau herr
schneeberger den abgeordneten zum
niederösterreichischen landtag und
klubobmann heinz müller
abgeordneter zum wiener landtag hannes
taborsky und abgeordneter zum
niederösterreichischen landtag jürgen
handler herzlich willkommen
wir freuen uns über die anwesenheit des
stellvertretenden generalstabschef
der streitkräfte des komponenten der
landesverteidigungsakademie des leiters
der vertretung brüssel des
medienbeauftragten
zahlreicher die reaktions und
dienststellenleiter genannten aller
führungsebenen der akademie unschuld
komponenten und für sie sowie für alle
offizieren unter für sie ihre begrüßen
die herzlichste und respektvoll den chef
des generalstabes und leiter der kanal t
zum landesverteidigung personal magister
robert bringen
generell glauben sie mir es
erfüllt die theresianischen
militärakademie mit stolz wenn ein
absolvent dieses hauses mit mitte des
nächsten jahres die funktion chairman
auf die european militär komitee antritt
und somit höchste offizier in der
europäischen union
als zeichen unserer internationalen
kooperation und vernetztheit ein
dankeschön für ihre anwesenheit allen in
österreich akkreditierten verteidigungs
militär und luftwaffe ist unter ihrem
neuen obersten als stärke
für religionsgemeinschaften begrüßen wir
seien extra militärbischof dr werner
freistetter herrn militär
superintendenten magister dr dr reinhard
trauner und herz priester dr dr dr
alexander p
aus dem bereich der personalvertretung
und sozialpartner ein willkommen dem
vorsitzenden des zentralausschusses
magister peter schropp visa sowie dem
vorsitzenden der bundesheergewerkschaft
minister alle hat minister walter hirsch
und mit ihnen den örtlichen dienstes
den vertretern der behörden und
einsatzorganisationen ein dank für ihre
anwesenheit und die hervorragende
zusammenarbeit herrn bezirkshauptmann
von wiener neustadt magister marcus
sauer herrn magistrats direkter magister
markus biebl und den präsidenten des
niederösterreichischen roten kreuzes
herrn josef smolle
ein herzliches willkommen den vertretern
unserer partner sowie
kooperationspartner für die
österreichische offiziersgesellschaft
herren präsidenten bringe dir magister
chicas für die fachhochschule wiener
neustadt herrn so magister peter er
locker für das landesklinikum wiener
neustadt ja ein universitäts professor
dr stadien und den repräsentanten
unseres jüngsten partners der stadt
wiener neustadt habe ich ja bereits
begrüßt
für eine angehörigen des ruhestandes
begrüßen wir die mal trug inspektoren
herrn general in ruhe kaum netzen auch
ihren präsident vereinigung hat neustadt
und general in ruhe was planer den
ehemaligen generalstabschef general
magister hätten und entdecker sowie die
generale in ruhe hessel höfler schuldig
secure kavanagh und channel
ein ganz besonderer willkommensgruß gilt
den offizieren des ausmusterung des
jahrganges schwarzenberg welche ihr
jubiläum feiern und vor 50 jahren hier
am maria theresien platz standen
abschließend gilt man groß allen
weiteren damen und herren die unserer
einladung gefolgt sind insbesondere den
angehörigen der heute im mittelpunkt
stehen noch visier alle wirklich den
heutigen festakt im livestream verfolgen
herzliche grüße aus wiener neustadt und
ein danke für ihr interesse
wann und wo wenn nicht heute
kann die militärakademie dank sagen
unser aufrichtiger dank der verbundes
ministerin im bundesministerium für
landesverteidigung den streitkräften den
waffen und fachschulen der kollegiums
leitung welche immer unseren
ausbildungsauftrag unterstützen mein
dank gilt meinem stellvertreter in
seinem staat sowie allen leitern und
komponenten mit ihrem lehrer forschungs
und ausbildungsplatz welche diesen
auftrag konsequent umsetzen und immer
weiterentwickeln ich wünsche den
offizieren des ausleuchtung des
jahrganges 20 1 1 -sieg alles erdenklich
gute und viel soldatenglück es lebe die
theresianischen militärakademie
es lebe die alma mater theresia
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrte frau minister hohe
festgäste
liebe anzuwenden leutnant liebe
kameraden in wenigen augenblicken werden
sie ihre angelobung formel sprechen wo
am ende dieser form das wort zu dienen
ist zu dienen bedeutet weniger nur das
tut tun zu tun was einem befohlen wird
oder was vielleicht einem genehm ist
es bedeutet dass man in schwierigen
situationen ohne viel zu fragen das
richtige tut und zwar mit vollen einsatz
mit dem ganzen herzen und mit dem ganzen
kräften es gibt nicht viele berufe der
qualität man an dem verständnis dieses
zu dienen beurteilt ich denke etwa an
die autobrände der lehrer oder
engagierte beamten oder etwa an die
ärzte die an vielen stationen
intensivstationen schwer kranke
patienten heute betreuen ohne viel zu
herum zu fragen mit viel mitgefühl und
oft mit ihren letzten kräften physisch
wie psychisch
sie haben liebe leut nannte eine
schwierige ausbildung absolviert an der
theresianischen alma mater
militärakademie und nun sind sie
hochschulabsolventen in dem baden wort
es ist anzunehmen dass sie in
zunehmendem maße mit vielen problemen
situationen konfrontiert werde wo die
anderen nicht weiter wissen wo ist nicht
genügt bloß nach vorschrift zu agieren
wo die loslösung solche probleme davon
abhängt wie weit man bereich ist mit dem
herz mit der ganzen persönlichkeit die
dinge anzupacken ja zum wohl derer die
ihnen anvertraut sind sowohl der die
sich den schutz und hilfe von ihnen
in diesem sinne möge der allmächtige
gott sie segnen der vater der sohn und
der heilige geist armen
seid gesegnet und ihr sollt ein segen
sein
segen bedeutet nichts anderes als dass
das leben gelingt nicht dass alle
probleme fern sind sondern dass ihr sie
bewältigt nicht dass ihr nur aufgaben
erfolgreich erfüllt sondern mehr dass
das leben eben gelingt und auch hier
sollte ein segen sein für ihre familie
für freunde eure kameraden untergebene
auch vorgesetzte er sollte auch als
offiziere dem leben dienen im privat und
berufsleben dass gerade beim militär
recht fordernd sein kann im extremfall
bis an die existenzielle bedrohung gehen
kann und doch geht es immer und das
fördern des gelungenen lebens
für diese aufgabe erbitte ich eher
bitten wir die hilfe und förderung den
segen gottes der über 1 steht
der herr segne euch und behüte euch der
herr lasse sein angesicht überall
leuchten und sei auch nötig wenn der
euch sein antlitz zu und schenke euch
seinen frieden
armen
hoch geehrte frau bundesminister
hohe geistlichkeit
geschätzte ehren und festgäste aus allen
bereichen von politik und gesellschaft
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
leuten an der der heutige tag ist ein
starkes zeichen für die grundlegende
zielsetzung der ausbildung unserer
offiziere nämlich das bestehen im
einsatz im dienste der sicherheit
österreichs und seiner menschen die
heute hier angetreten damals und herren
leutnant konnten bereits während ihrer
ausbildung ihrer fertigkeiten im einsatz
beweisen und erste führungserfahrungen
sammeln und ich möchte hinzufügen dass
sie ihre aufgaben weil es junge
kommandanten gemeinsam mit den ihnen
zugeordneten milizsoldaten
vollständig erfüllt haben daher ist es
auch wichtig und selbstverständlich dass
heute alle berufs- und mediziner
gemeinsam in die gruppe übernommen
werden ich bin sehr froh dass wir alle
heute diesen besonderen tag begehen
können und sei es wie auch im
vergangenen jahr unter einschränkenden
auflagen
dieser tag der absolvierung ihrer
offiziersausbildung soll ihnen meine
damen und herren leute immer in stolzer
erinnerung bleiben markiert hat auch den
einstieg ins berufsleben und die
übernahme von verantwortung über die
ihnen anvertrauten jungen menschen
das österreichische bundesheer befindet
sich in einer phase der neuausrichtung
es gilt verfahren struktur und
ausrüstung sukzessive so auszurichten
dass die streitkräfte den komplexen
risken und bedrohungen des beginnenden
21 jahrhunderts gewachsen sind das
besondere dieser neuen herausforderungen
aufgabenstellungen liegt darin dass
österreich wie auch alle unsere
europäischen partner sie nur im wege
enger kooperation werden bewältigen
können
österreich wird als teil der
europäischen union nur gemeinsam mit den
anderen mitgliedsstaaten und
partnernationen die zukunft mit den
großen herausforderungen wie klimawandel
energieknappheit
migration
terrorismus mögliche pandemien etc
gestalten können
jüngste entwicklung anzeigen neuerlich
dass die europäische union
eigenständig handlungsfähig werden muss
und österreich soll hier konstruktiv
mitwirken
wir verstehen uns als verlässlicher
partner im internationalen krisen
management unsere beitragsleistung für
eine sich entwickelnde gemeinsame
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik
wird somit dieser ambition rechnung zu
tragen haben
das österreichische bundesheer ist das
sicherheitsgarant der republik
um seine aufgaben zu erfüllen bedarf es
neben gut ausgebildeten personal auch
einer zeitgemäßen ausrüstung und und
sichtlich der vorher angeführten neuen
aufgaben einer modernen infrastruktur
die budgetentwicklung gestattet die
realisierung der vordringlichsten
vorhaben ohne die unsere soldaten den
schutz der bevölkerung nicht zu
gewährleisten imstande wären als
militärische führung sind wir
verpflichtet fähigkeit defizite zu
benennen und der politischen führung
prioritäten für deren schrittweise
behebung vorzuschlagen
ich darf daher die gelegenheit nutzen
die politisch verantwortlichen und deren
weitere unterstützung zur sicherstellung
einer kontinuierlichen
aufwärtsentwicklung des
verteidigungshaushalts zu ersuchen
das österreichische bundesheer ist
bestrebt mit zahlreichen initiativen und
projekten die aktuellen
herausforderungen zu adressieren
ich denke hier beispielsweise an die
autarkie unserer kasernen wenn nur wenn
wir etwa bei einem blackout ereignis
unsere eigenen überlebens und
führungsfähigkeit erhalten werden wir
auch gemeinsam mit den anderen behörden
der bevölkerung zu hilfe kommen können
eine weitere unmittelbare bedrohung
resultiert aus dem missbrauch des cyber
raums ich weise darauf hin dass die
terroristische militärakademie im
nächsten studienjahr ab herbst
2022 einen richtungsweisenden
baywa studiengang für offiziere eröffnen
wird
die offiziere aus diesem studiengang
werden neben der ausbildung zum offizier
der führungsunterstützung ganz spezielle
fachleute in der cyber abwehr sein deren
gesellschaft deren die gesellschaft
insgesamt dringend bedarf
oder denken sie an unsere bemühungen den
umweltschutz und dem
verantwortungsvollen umgang mit den
knappen ressourcen mehr aufmerksamkeit
zu widmen dies reicht von der förderung
der elektromobilität und der nutzung
öffentlicher verkehrsmittel im ressort
bis zur beschaffung von saisonal
verfügbaren lebensmittel vorwiegend aus
der regionalen umgebung der kaserne
geschätzte damen und herren leutnant der
das aktiv und miliz standes des jaguar
regiment herzog von lothringen nummer 7
abgeleitet von dem modernen
bedrohungsbild und nach maßgabe der zur
verfügung stehenden ressourcen liegt das
schwergewicht der ausbildung zukünftig
auf den grundlegenden militärischen
fähigkeiten der soldaten aller
waffengattungen
also den sogenannten kernfähigkeiten
nach längerer zeit der umfassenden
unterstützung unserer zivilen behörden
im zusammenhang mit der kobe pandemie
ist es unsere absicht die militärischen
kompetenzen wieder schrittweise zu
erhöhen und zu festigen
ja wir helfen überall nach kräften wo
man uns braucht aber die voraussetzung
dieser umfassenden unterstützung
beziehungsweise assistenz für das
gemeinwohl ist eben unser militärisches
alleinstellungsmerkmal in
organisatorischer ausbildungs und
ausrüstungsmängel hinsicht nur wenn wir
unsere militärischen kernaufgaben
welcher waffengattung auch immer
beherrschen werden wir auch zukünftig
helfen wo andere nicht mehr können
das was den soldaten aus macht loyalität
disziplin ordnung führenden strafen
strukturen selbstständigkeit
durchhaltevermögen und die fähigkeit
lageangepasst rasch und zielstrebig auch
in die gefahr hin ein zu handeln
benötigt er in allen einsätzen im krieg
in der krise im friedensdienst sowie
beim schutz und hilfe aufgaben zum wohle
der bevölkerung
ich erwarte von ihnen meine damen und
herren leuten und dass sie alle
persönlichen fähigkeiten und jene
fertigkeiten die sie im rahmen der
ausbildung an der theresianischen
militärakademie erworben haben gepaart
mit einem respektvollen führungsstil
linien kommenden dienst einfließen
lassen begegnen sie ihren vorgesetzten
kameraden und untergebenen mit respekt
und achtung
nehmen sie sich für die führung auch
zeit denn führen bedeutet auch den
soldaten zuzuhören sich vor sie zu
stellen wenn sie ihres schutzes bedürfen
führen sie initiativ und von vorne und
lassen sie sich nicht durch eine auf den
ersten blick immense verwaltungs last
abschrecken ihr platz ist draußen bei
uns soldaten
in den vergangenen drei studienjahren
haben sie sich ihre persönlichen beruf
und folgend auf einen beruf vorbereitet
der dem frieden und der sicherheit
unserer heimat und der freiheit sowie
dem wohlergehen unserer mitmenschen
dient bleiben sie offen für neuerungen
das berufsbild des offiziers unterliegt
dynamischen veränderungen wenn man sie
durch lebenslanges lernen gegnern werden
sie haben das dragoner regiment nummer 7
zu ihrem jahrgangs namen gewählt diese
wahl scheint mir wohl überlegt sie
gefällt mir umso mehr als es sich bei
dem dragone regiments 7 um einen
österreichischen verband handelt der in
seiner über 250 jährigen geschichte
sowie der regiments inhaber selbst
herzog alba fünfte leopold von
lothringen und bar besonders in
einsätzen ausgezeichnet hat gegründet im
jahr
1683 im zusammenhang mit der abwehr der
sich das sich ausdehnende osmanischen
reiches beteiligt und dem einsatz an dem
einsatz der hauptstadt wien im jahr 1683
konnte das regiment in allen
wesentlichen kriege und schlachten des
achtzehnten und neunzehnten jahrhunderts
bis in den ersten weltkrieg hinein
seinen zusammenhalt seine treue und
seine herausragenden militärischen
fähigkeiten unter beweis stellen dass
dragoner regiment nummer 7 hat in seiner
geschichte soldatischen tugenden gelebt
die zeitlos genannt werden dürfen und
ihnen vorbild sein sollen ich gratuliere
ihnen herzlich zur erfolgreichen
ausbildung zum offizier des
österreichischen bundesheeres und der
damit verbundene beförderung zum
leutnant ich wünsche ihnen den
erwarteten beruflichen erfolg gesundheit
und die nötige kraft sowie persönliche
erfüllung bei den vor ihnen liegenden
aufgaben im dienste unserer heimat der
republik österreich und ihrer
bevölkerung
das leben der jahrgang dragoner elemente
nummer sieben ist lebe die
theresianischen militärakademie
ist lebe das österreichische bundesheer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrte damen und herren sie hören
nun in vertretung des herrn
bundespräsidenten die ansprache der frau
bundesministerin für landesverteidigung
und danach erfolgt die verleihung des
offiziers an den jahrgangs ersten des
jahrganges tragen regiments 7 leutnant
nikolaus barack obama danach spielt die
militärmusik die festmusik von weber
sehr geehrte exzellenz nun hohe
geistlichkeit sehr geehrter herr
generalstabschef ehren und festgäste vor
allem herr bürgermeister sehr geehrte
kommandanten offiziere soldatinnen und
soldaten und ganz besonders sehr
geehrter absolventen und absolventinnen
des jahrgangs dragoner regiment 7 sehr
geehrte leugnende
die letzten eineinhalb jahre waren für
die bundesregierung aber auch für unser
land im allgemeinen eine unglaublich
herausfordernde zeit die carola pandemie
hat nahezu jedes ressort stark betroffen
neben der bewältigung der pandemie
konnten wir aber auch sehr wichtige
gesetzesinitiativen setzen auch
entlastungsmaßnahmen in der höhe von 18
milliarden euro für die bürgerinnen und
bürger unseres landes das zeigt klar
diese regierung arbeitet für die
menschen in diesem land aber
auch in bewegten zeiten müssen wir
flexibel sein und die an uns gestellten
aufgaben erfüllen und das weiß wohl
niemand so genau wie das österreichische
bundesheer
sehr geehrte leutnant de heute ist ein
großer tag heute ist ein großer tag für
sie in ihrer karriere als offizier ein
großer tag für das bundesheer und ein
großer tag für die republik österreich
denn heute werden sie als offiziere des
österreichischen bundesheers ihnen das
österreichische bundesheer übernommen
mit ihnen steht hier die nächste
generation die für die sicherheit
unserer bevölkerung für die sicherheit
von uns ein in österreich sorgen wird
die jungen damen und herren des
jahrgangs tag ohne regiment 7 die hier
vor uns stehen sehr geehrte damen und
herren
haben sich ihren abschluss wahrlich hat
verdient denn die kogit 19 pandemie hat
vieles in der ausbildung erschwert
zum einen normal corona bedingte phasen
des fernunterrichts
einberufung auch zur assistenz einsetzen
um dort führungsfunktionen innerhalb der
aufgebotenen miliz kompanie zu
übernehmen ich hoffe aber auch die
möglichkeit erlerntes wissen zur
anwendung zu bringen theorie in die
praxis umzusetzen und wertvolle
erfahrungen zu sammeln
sehr geehrte leuten under
als angehende offiziere haben sie
während ihrer langen währenden ihrer
fordernden und anspruchsvollen
ausbildung
bewiesen dass sie die fähigkeiten
besitzen andere menschen zu führen sie
sind aufgerufen in zukunft mit hoher
verantwortung umzugehen wenn sie
staatsbürger und staatsbürgerinnen so
soldaten ausbilden und wenn sie ihnen
unterstellt die offiziere unteroffiziere
und schafen im inland und im ausland in
schwierigen und manchmal auch heiklen
einsätzen führen
und dass
das wird wichtiger denn je denn eines
ist ein faktum die sicherheitslage
sicherheitslage in europa wird sich in
den nächsten
kommenden jahr nicht verbessern und die
herausforderungen die werden steigen das
zeigt uns das risikobild der nächsten
jahre die gute nachricht ist wir wissen
einigermaßen was auf uns zukommt und wir
können und wir müssen uns
dementsprechend
vorbereiten ich spreche hier von den
herausforderungen szenarien des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts wie
terrorismus cyberattacken
naturkatastrophen blackouts und
pandemien
naturkatastrophen mit ihren folgen und
in dem entsprechenden einsätzen des
bundesheeres haben wir in den
vergangenen
jahren ja jahrzehnten
zur genüge erlebt wahrscheinlich werden
sie durch den klimawandel noch weiter
zunehmen aber wer hätte es jemals
gedacht er hätte es jemals gedacht dass
es zu einer pandemie kommt die auch
österreich erfasst und doch ist es
passiert wer hätte jemals gedacht dass
er eine terroranschlag gibt wie im
vergangenen jahr mitten in wien und doch
hat dieser albtraum stattgefunden und
wer hätte vor ein paar jahren noch ein
blackout für möglich gehalten und doch
sagen alle sicherheitsexperten es wird
passieren
ein einzelnes realist
realistisches szenario denn ein
europaweiter strominfrastruktur
versorgungsausfall der kann immer
möglich sein und unsere aufgabe als
österreichisches bundesheer ist es in so
einem fall dass wir die
führungsfähigkeit der republik
unterstützen und im katastrophenfall den
anderen einsatzorganisationen als
strategische reserve helfen können und
diese neuen szenarien sind der grund
dass der generalstabschef auch schon
angeführt warum zum beispiel an der
militärakademie ein neuer studiengang
eingeführt wird der fachhochschule
bachelorstudiengang militärischer
informations und
kommunikationstechnologie führung
wenn wir auch stark eingesetzt waren in
der pandemie oder noch sind zum höchsten
zeitpunkt mit 8000 soldatinnen und
soldaten von denen viele aus der miliz
stammen dann bedeutet das aber nicht
dass wir auf die ursprünglichen aufgaben
der landesverteidigung vergessen dürfen
denn
wie heißt es so treffend
wer verteidigen kann der kann auch
helfen aber werden nur helfen kann der
kann nicht verteidigen daher muss es
auch immer unser anspruch sein
österreich als neutrales land im herzen
europas militärisch adäquat auf die
beine zu stellen auf stabile beine zu
stellen und das bedeutet dass wir auch
in diesem bereich weiter investieren
investieren müssen um die erforderlichen
militärischen kern kompetenzen und
fähigkeiten zu erhalten
daraus folgt wir wollen noch mehr in die
b cyber abwehr drohnen abwehr abc abwehr
terrorabwehr investieren gleichzeitig
müssen wir vorsorge treffen unser
bundesheer in teilbereichen insbesondere
in kasernen betrieb autark und damit
natürlich
krisenfester zu machen
generell geht es um viele neue
beschaffungen die mobilität ausrüstung
im gerät dass das bundesheer zu einem
modernen her macht gilt kann man nie
genug haben aber mit dem erhöhten budget
und den sonderfinanzierungen die wir uns
gemeinsam ausverhandelt haben werden wir
das auch schaffen
die theresianischen militärakademie
wird seit jahrhunderten als die heimat
der österreichischen offiziere nicht nur
für die berufsoffizier sondern auch für
die miliz offizieren das zusammenspiel
von berufs offizieren und miliz
offizieren das wird in zukunft immer
wichtiger werden nicht nur zur
klassischen landesverteidigung sondern
auch darüber hinaus die miliz soldaten
und soldatinnen sind ein wesentlicher
bestandteil des österreichischen
bundesheeres und ihre
einsatzbereitschaft ist in
sicherheitspolitisch herausfordernden
zeiten ganz besonders wichtig und da
braucht es unterstützung da braucht es
größtmögliche unterstützung durch die
berufssoldaten um die miliz kräfte
sinnvoll in das system bundesheer zu
integrieren das ist mir ein ganz
besonderes anliegen nicht nur weiß in
der verfassung steht sondern weil ich
zutiefst davon überzeugt bin dass das
milizsystem die richtige form der
landesverteidigung für unsere republik
ist deshalb ist es auch so wichtig dass
heute hier berufssoldaten und
milizsoldaten gemeinsam in einer reihe
stehen
sehr geehrte offiziere und lehrer der
theresianischen militärakademie
ich danke ihnen ich danke ihnen für all
die arbeit und mühe die sie in ihrer
ausbildung der fähnriche in all den
jahren gesteckt haben jetzt sind die
jungen soldatinnen und soldaten zu
leuten geworden und werden sicher immer
wieder
einmal zurück in ihre akademische heimat
finden und auch vieles während der
ausbildung geschehene im gedächtnis
behalten
ich möchte meinen dank aber auch an die
eltern an die
lebenspartnerinnen und partnern die
freunde und an die familien richten denn
auch sie haben und tragen die
folgenreiche persönliche entscheidung
mit dem eigenen land als offizier zu
dienen
sehr geehrte angehörige ich danke ihnen
ich danke ihnen herzlich für diese
unterstützung die sie persönlich diesen
männern und frauen im dienste der
republik österreich geben
sehr geehrte leutnant der miliz und
berufsoffiziere es ist mir heute auch
eine ehre den vom oberbefehlshaber
bundespräsident alexander van der bellen
gestifteten ehren säbel an den
jahrgangsbesten
stellvertretend für den gesamten
ausmusterung jahrgang dragoner regiment
7 zu überreichen ich gratuliere ihnen
ich gratuliere ihnen zu erfolgreichen
absolvierung der offiziersausbildung und
der damit verbundenen beförderung zum
leutnant sie muss dann in einer zeit aus
die von der gesamten sicherheitslage
hier ausgesehen schwieriger wird und sie
müssen sich daher auch auf diese
zukünftigen herausforderungen
einstellen sie beginnen einen neuen
lebensabschnitt in ihrer militärischen
laufbahn sie treten einen neue zeiten
dazu wünsche ich ihnen alles gute für
die zukunft viel erfolg und das dazu
notwendige
soldatenglück es lebe die
theresianischen militärakademie
es lebe das österreichische bundesheer
es lebe die republik österreich
[Applaus]
leutnant nico skiba
meldet sich zur übergabe
vielen dank für die meldung herr
leutnant und herzliche gratulation zu
dieser herausragenden leistung ich darf
ihnen mit großer freude diese nähren
säbel überreichen und ihnen alles
erdenklich gute wünschen herzliche
gratulation viel soldatenglück
frau bundesminister ich übernehme diesen
selber im namen meines jahrgangs 20 21
dragoner regiment 7 halten in ehren zum
schutz unserer heimat und seiner
menschen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir kommen nun zum höhepunkt des
heutigen festaktes dem treuegelöbnis der
leitende der jahrgangssprecher des
jahrganges truck und sieben leuten an
peter timm hof wird das treuegelöbnis
verlesen nach dem darauf folgenden
marsch oder in österreich erfolgt daher
bieten weitere befehle
[Musik]
abordnungen vertreten
bis hierher
kameradinnen und kameraden spricht mir
nach ich glaube
mein vaterland
die republik österreich
und sein volk zu schützen und
mit der waffe zu verteidigen
ich gelobe
den gesetzen und den gesetzmäßigen
behörden
treue und gehorsam zu leisten
alle befehle meiner vorgesetzten
[Applaus]
pünktlich und genau zu befolgen
mit all meinen kräften
der republik österreich
[Applaus]
und der österreichischen volk
zu dienen
argument ein dritter
die fahne der militärakademie eintreten
[Musik]
das ganze parade und
meine damen und herren der kommandant
der ausrichten truppe wo was die hat
fleischmann wird nun das ende des
festaktes melden und im anschluss
marschiert die ehrenformation aus ich
darf sie bieten am zugewiesenen
sitzplatz zu verbleiben und den
anweisungen die sie nach dem ausmaß
verhalten zum geordneten verlassen des
veranstaltungsortes folge zu leisten
[Musik]
pressemeldung an die frau bundesminister
das ganze
frau bundesminister norbert fleischmann
meldet die beendigung des festaktes und
bittet um weitere befehle
vielen dank für diesen würdigen festakt
abrücken lassen abrücken
das ganze
ist
schon
was
ganz
gut
das ganze hat
balkan japan schule rechts um
die offiziere recht
der will reicht das ganze reich
das ganze app schritt
[Musik]
[Applaus]